bonsoir et bienvenue dans kiosque votre
magazine culturel au sommaire ce soir le
samedi à 21 mars jour du printemps
également journée de la poésie nous
sommes allés en cours pour suivre une
séance de poème matin Philippe découvre
découfflée présente contact au Théâtre
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les
premiers deux et trois avril un
spectacle dans le spectacle et puis
comme toutes les semaines un
professionnel du septième art de notre
secteur donne son coup de cœur ce soir
Cyril la date des Clayes-sous-Bois mais
donc tout de suite on démarre avec une
page de poésie samedi c'était la journée
mondiale
et à l'occasion donc de cette journée
mondiale de la poésie la médiathèque
Jean Rousselot de Guyancourt a reçu
comédien et artiste au programme de la
poésie vagabonde en passant par du poète
Mathon toutes les explications avec
Mathilde caberne et Patrick
ils ne m'ont pas bien ils montent
seulement à la hauteur de mon cœur à la
hauteur d'un champ de coq à la hauteur
de la vie Jean de La Fontaine Rimbaud
cela vous rappelle certainement de
nombreux souvenirs depuis une dizaine
d'années l'UNESCO encourage la lecture
la rédaction et l'enseignement de la
poésie dans le monde entier l'objectif
donner une reconnaissance et une
impulsion nouvelle la poésie n'est pas
un style oubliée bien au contraire
d'abord c'est pas un style pour moi
c'est pas du tout un style c'est une
façon d'être une façon de se comporter
dans le monde après il y a l'écriture et
la poésie c'est d'abord et avant tout un
travail sur la langue et c'est ça qui
est essentiel au 21ème siècle il y a des
poètes nous on montre qu'il y a des
poètes aujourd'hui et ils sont là et on
à travers la voix des comédiens
ce qui peut y avoir entre les sons les
arts plastiques et les mots
on aime bien vraiment de voir comment un
mot résonne et quelle résonance il donne
au niveau son et on trouve que la
position prête vraiment bien à ce type
de d'exercice autre dispositif le
pot-hématon son inventrice Isabelle
poquet incite à la curiosité et invite
une expérience intime où l'on murmure
moséri mal oreille elle cherchait une
un moyen de faire entendre de la poésie
contemporaine dans les meilleures
conditions et partout et donc elle a
imaginé cette cabine sur le modèle du
photomaton pour le Printemps des Poètes
il y a 4 ans
et depuis le poème attend voyage un peu
dans toute la France au gré des
invitations pour faire entendre la
poésie contemporaine partout il vous
suffit de rentrer et d'écouter puis
laisser place à votre imagination
l'envers du décor vu par à Philippe
découfflé avec contact une création au
Théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines qui invite
le spectateur à être un peu plus qu'un
spectateur hommage aux comédies
musicales et à ceux qui les font Nicolas
Gervais a rencontré le chorégraphe pour
nous
chorégraphe danseur créateur de
spectacle Toto il peut collaborer avec
le Crazy Horse comme il peut mettre en
scène des cérémonies Olympiques qui
s'intéressent aujourd'hui à la comédie
musicale avec le spectacle contact que
vous pourrez voir notamment du premier
au 3 avril au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alors contact est un spectacle un
spectaculaire
dans lequel j'ai mis beaucoup de choses
je crois que j'aimais
il y a de la danse il y a du chant donc
ça c'est vraiment la dimension nouvelle
c'est que tout le monde chante il y a de
la musique live je jouais par Nosfell et
Pierre Lebourgeois et puis il est
danseurs et comédien joue aussi de la
musique avec eux donc la musique est
très importante la musique originale est
vraiment je crois forte j'avais envie de
me confronter au genre de la comédie
musicale comme on en parlait tout à
l'heure comme je auparavant je m'étais
intéressé au strip-tease ou c'est un
genre qui est en tant que tel
m'intéresse parce que parce qu'il m'a
fasciné enfant
mon amour de la danse vient beaucoup de
comédie musicale que ma maman m'a
emmenée voir notamment des films de Fred
Astaire Jane Kelly ou stormy weather
avec les Nicolas Brothers ce qui était
les plus grands danseur avec la quête du
monde Phantom of the Paradise de Brian
De Palma qui m'a beaucoup marqué
l'envie de faire un spectacle total et
puis l'envie de faire un truc sur le
genre comme et des Musicales de voir
qu'est-ce que je pouvais faire avec ça
aujourd'hui comment le genre comédie
musicale pouvait être déringardisé en
quelque sorte et puis ensuite il y a une
variation sur fausse on a pris fausse
comme thème et donc il y a des
allers-retours entre comme toujours dans
mes spectacles des passages qui sont
plus qui sont très oniriques et des
passages où on revient sur une 127ème
version de Faust un peu délirante comme
ça
en fait je suis un peu un cinéaste
frustré moi j'aurais aimé faire du
cinéma et je fais des spectacles mais je
suis quand même très heureux en faisant
des spectacles et du coup je mince c'est
vrai que notamment dans ce spectacle là
les inspirations viennent beaucoup plus
du cinéma que d'ailleurs et je pense que
c'est un genre c'est aussi pour ça que
j'avais envie de voir ce que ça pouvait
donner en spectacle c'est la comédie
musicale est un genre qui a priori
réussi mieux au cinéma j'adorerais
j'adorerais effectivement vous faire une
version cinéma une version film qui
serait pas du tout la même chose
on ne se fait il se trouve qu'on a
effectivement fait ensemble un premier
spectacle Octopus et que j'avais été
émerveillé par son talent je trouve
qu'il a une voix extraordinaire il est
capable d'aller de l'Opéra aigu à des
graves très profondes mais c'est un
binôme avec Pierre Lebourgeois donc
Nosfell chante compose écrit et Pierre
écrit aussi elle fait des arrangements
assez riches et l'alchimie des deux
me permettent de travailler dans un
certain bonheur et de et d'avoir un
éventail musical assez ouvert il y a un
disque contact qui est sorti qui est en
vente à la à la sortie du spectacle
il y a un décor de Jean rabas très beau
et très impressionnant
c'est assez expressionniste ça nous
permet de magnifier le spectacle de
rythmé la danse c'est très visuel c'est
un spectacle rapide de visuel enlevé
multiple qui marche avec les enfants
comme avec les vieux
là ils sont je crois 13 danseurs plus
les deux musiciens ils sont 15 et
effectivement ce n'est que des gens avec
lesquels j'avais déjà travaillé c'est
très important pour moi la la fidélité
j'ai pas envie j'ai envie d'essayer de
creuser le sillon un petit peu plus loin
chaque fois et pas de pas de tout
recommencer
donc là j'avais envie de travailler avec
des gens que je connaissais avec qui
j'étais en confiance c'était important
pour moi
de plus ils ont du talent et quand on
bosse ensemble on découvre des nouvelles
facettes chez les gens qu'on a envie de
faire ressortir au spectacle suivant
supposons Dieu dans un plan et sous la
figure symbolique de trois ou droites
égales quoi de longueur
issus d'un même point et faisant entre
elles des angles de 120 degrés une des
nombreuses idées de départ de ce
spectacle c'était un hommage à Pina
baoch j'étais un grand fan de Pinat et
si on regarde en ma troupe où il y a des
écartages ça va de 25 à plus de 60 ans
et puis des tempéraments des types de
corps très différents je me suis dit ah
mais j'ai une troupe un petit peu qui me
fait penser un petit peu à ce que
j'avais vu chez pinnac au contact c'est
le début de contact of qui est la
première pièce de Pina Bao parce que
j'ai vu quand j'avais une vingtaine
d'années
c'est comme d'habitude en réalité un
spectacle qui se peaufine et qui se met
au point en tournée le les réactions du
public des spectateurs mettent beaucoup
à comprendre ce qui fonctionne ou pas et
à affiner le tir si je sens quelque
chose ne marche pas ou que ça marche
trop bien d'ailleurs le spectacle n'est
pas deux fois identique c'est de l'art
vivant et même si la structure est assez
forte c'est constamment en mouvement le
plaisir de danser le plaisir de partager
avec le public des moments forts voilà
plaisir de plaisir d'offrir je vois de
recevoir
et après de souffler on garde le contact
avec Catherine
elle est comme tous les mercredis la
chronique cinéphile et nous démarrons
tout de suite avec vos avis de
spectateurs éclairés
c'est sympa c'est sympa c'est sans plus
ça fera pas un grand film de Will Smith
je m'attendais mieux c'est une petite
comédie sympa mais sans plus c'est un
bon film moi je trouve que c'était un
bon film mais par contre voilà ce qu'il
y a une bonne fin j'ai bien aimé la fin
on s'attend pas c'est l'histoire de
jeunes qui habitent dans la région du
Nord à Lille exactement et le garçon est
vétérinaire la une des deux filles
avocate et la troisième
elle travaille pas et donc
ils sont amis entre eux et
c'est un peu spécial après ben voilà il
se retrouve à vivre ensemble tous les
trois et assez mis tous les trois voilà
Cendrillon et
j'ai aimé le bal aussi surtout pour les
petites filles je pense que c'est bien
pour les petites filles pour les garçons
bon il a bien aimé mais je pense que un
peu moins
cette semaine notre coup de cœur est le
dessin animé gus petit oiseau grand
voyageur
alors du départ pour la grande migration
Darius le doyen de la volée est blessé
il va devoir confier ses secrets et le
nouvel itinéraire du voyage au premier
oiseau venu et cet oiseau c'est notre
héros exalté à l'idée de découvrir enfin
le monde mais pas du tout migrateur le
dessin animé réussi à mêler récit
initiatique anecdote pédagogique sur
l'ornithologie et sens de l'humour
délicat
comme on dit j'ai pris mon envol
il est le seul à connaître votre
nouvelle itinéraire nouvelle itinéraire
à cause des oiseaux de fer il y en a
partout il n'y a que lui qui sache
comment les éviter des oiseaux faire
c'est totalement insensé on est là
écoutez les délires d'un insecte les
tout-petits apprécieront la candeur du
message d'ouverture et de tolérance ce
joli petit film familial dégage beaucoup
de tendresse et de douceur ce petit piaf
craquant ne laissera pas insensible je
ne public ce compte qui donne des ailes
est un petit bijou d'animation et
s'inscrit comme une vraie réussite
techniquement le résultat est épatant ce
dessin animé est à découvrir cette
semaine en famille à l'espace Philippe
Noiret
et avant de se guider deux dates
musicales sera sur la scène de la Ferme
du Manet de Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce
samedi soir elle vient présenter son
nouveau spectacle Sheila le show entouré
de danseurs et choristes un show pour
ouvrir revivre les tubes des années 60 à
la grande époque disco tarifs à partir
de 29 € en voici un extrait je n'ai peur
de rien de rien du tout me croyez vous
cassoulet
je n'entends parler
loups bien les tours
la musique qui conclue que tout plus que
tout
et un autre style maintenant Gaspard
Royan sur la scène de l'estaminet de
Manille et un mot ce vendredi soir le
chanteur nous fait voyager dans les
années mythiques des cysties et s'impose
comme un crooner rétro des temps
modernes tu arrives à partir de 5 euros
cette émission maintenant terminée merci
d'avoir suivi je vous en rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
émission d'ici la garder l'esprit ouvert
et curieux bonne soirée